Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
[ All cheering ]
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
Joyce's Lulu Bang
will have you screaming...
"Bang!"
It's our best line of defense.
The market potential here
is huge.
So, first of all,
your name sucks.
I appreciate that.
This is a new concept.
You're asking for $500,000.
You ripped off
my royalty deal?
I did.
Yeah, baby!
I have an offer for you.
‐You do?!
‐[ Chuckling ] I do.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
If you guys
loved it so much,
how come not a dime
from any of you?
This is "Shark Tank."
I told them the truth.
I didn't have
to give them an excuse.
Shame on you.
♪♪
I'm Jorrae.
And I'm Kelly.
And we're sisters from
Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
You know
why it's gonna be really good?
'Cause you made it.
Because I made it.
I'll tell you the truth.
We've cooked all our lives.
We love to cook.
My mom
was the best cook ever.
We would go to church
on Sundays, come home,
and she would tear
the kitchen up.
So it's very important
that we continue the tradition.
Whoo!
How about this?
One dinner four years ago,
I couldn't find the taste
that I wanted,
so I decided
to make it myself.
Here you go.
Eat up.
When we tried it, everyone
said it was the best thing
they had ever tasted.
Everybody enjoying the food?
‐Oh, yeah!
‐Yeah!
And from that point,
we decided to give it a name.
Lulu Bang.
We named the product
after our brother Mike,
whose nickname
was Lulu Bang.
He was carjacked and taken away
from us, tragically,
and it's our way
of keeping his legacy alive.
Having a Shark
taste our product
and validate
that it is real good
will just make this journey
all the more sweeter.
♪♪
Both: Hi.
We're the Beard sisters.
I'm Jorrae.
And my name is Kelly.
And we're from
Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
We're seeking $150,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Now, Sharks, let's face it.
If you're like us,
you like to bang.
It's one of the few simple joys
and pleasures in life.
And if you're like me,
you want to bang
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
We've created
a masterpiece product line...
What?
...that will have you
wanting to...
bang everything.
Bang everything.
So, without further ado,
we would like
to introduce you
to Joyce's Lulu Bang.
Bang.
Our unique sauces
are infused
with herbs, spices,
and natural flavors
that will literally change
the way you eat.
Joyce's Lulu Bang
will have you screaming...
"Bang!"
But what's most unique
about our product line
is that it is beautiful
on anything,
from seafood, poultry,
pork, and steak
to rice, pasta salads,
and potatoes.
You name it...
we can bang it.
We can bang it.
So, who wants
to partner with us
and bang that thang with...
Joyce's Lulu Bang?
Joyce's Lulu Bang.
We have samples
for you guys to try.
‐Bang that thang!
Greiner:
Bang, bang, bang.
I'd dike to introduce
our daughter, Ashley.
She's gonna provide samples
for you.
‐That's your daughter?
‐Yes, that's my daughter.
‐Wow, great.
‐Wow!
I just turned 50
this year, guys.
‐Congratulations. Absolutely.
‐You look amazing.
‐You do look amazing.
‐Gorgeous.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you so much, Ashley.
‐You're welcome.
‐So, what that means is,
our sauce is so amazing...
Thank you.
...you can literally eat it
on anything.
So, we prepared
four different dishes.
We have
our famous Lulu Bang Wangs.
We actually have
our seafood fried rice,
our vegetable medley,
and then we have a fajita‐style
chicken and steak.
Mmm!
So, what we wanted to do was
allow you guys an opportunity
to taste the sauce in its...
‐Mmm.
Kelly: ...you know,
just in its purest state.
‐Pretty good.
‐It's very good.
Kelly: A person that usually
is not really a good cook ‐‐
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
‐The Asian I love.
‐You like it?
You like it? Yes.
So, what we wanted
to really share with you guys
is how awesome it is,
and the fact
that you can use it on anything.
These are your recipes?
‐Yes.
‐Every last one.
O'Leary: One of the
great challenges of ‐‐
of barbecue sauces ‐‐
and we've had
our fair share of them
over the years
on "Shark Tank"...
Shipping and shelf space.
... we've tasted great sauce,
and this is as good as any.
Mm‐hmm.
Right.
That's not gonna be a problem.
Your sauce is great.
No one ever brings a sauce in
here and says it's not banging.
Yeah.
‐Right, right.
O'Leary: So, this is
a banging good sauce.
Yeah, but this ‐‐ this ‐‐
this is amazing sauce.
But you've got to tell us what
your distribution strategy is
to get market share
in the sauce business,
which is brutally competitive.
Oh, we would love
to share that story.
We started in catering
and restaurants.
Everyone kept telling us
the sauce is the bomb.
Right.
I mean, it's just amazing.
And so we started selling it
on small scale.
What happened was, the largest
retailer in the world, Walmart,
did a manufacturing summit
last year.
So we pitched our product,
and we pretty much ‐‐
O'Leary: To Walmart?
To Walmart.
And what happened?
What happened?
Kelly: 800 manufacturers.
At the end of the day, we walked
away with a regional deal.
We're in 170 stores.
Yeah.
You're in 170 Walmart stores?
It is so hard to get into
Walmart for a small business.
Right.
Tell us about
your Walmart journey.
What's the plan? Are they gonna
roll you out to more stores?
So, again, we've just started
with them in March.
Right.
We've already been connected
to the Women's Initiative ‐‐
the Women's Economic Initiative.
I was gonna ask you that.
Right.
I've had conversations
with my senior buyers,
and she actually said, and I‐I
really don't toot my own horn,
but when we went and presented,
she said we were the best
that she's ever seen.
Okay, okay, would they...
Kelly, we never asked ‐‐
What does it cost?
Kelly: Right now,
we are manufacturing,
including packaging
and all of that, for $1.90.
And what does it sell for?
It sells for $3.99 retail.
In the three months
since you've started,
how much have you sold?
We've sold a total of ‐‐ in
Walmart by itself ‐‐ $45,000.
How many
are you selling a week?
Do you know?
So, we sell about 500 a week.
Wow, that's low.
How much are you selling
right now online?
Oh, yeah,
we're not selling a lot online.
John: You know,
170 stores, 500 a week
is an average of only 2 1/2
bottles a week per store.
That's our challenge, you know,
because we're so brand‐new.
Yeah.
I don't think
this is gonna work.
This is never gonna be
a big online business.
I'm sorry.
It weighs too much.
And it's a competitive space.
It's a commodity.
To differentiate your product,
this is
a massive branding exercise.
Mm‐hmm.
In other words, you need
a lot more than $150,000.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they're concerned
about the low sales
of Kelly and Jorrae's
sauce company, Lulu Bang,
despite being
in numerous locations.
I don't think
this is gonna work.
You need
a lot more than $150,000
to break into the big leagues.
I'm sorry, ladies.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you for that.
Thank you so much
for your feedback.
You know, Kevin,
time‐out.
You sell online
glass jarred cupcakes.
Yes. And they weigh ‐‐
They're glass.
They weigh 1/10 of this.
Our whole deal
is to take the weight out.
They're not liquid.
I've lived this nightmare.
The whole shipping thing
is beyond a challenge.
John: Let me ‐‐
Let me give you my thoughts.
First of all, great.
The food ‐‐ amazing.
It is ‐‐ The sauce, bring
a tear to a glass eye, right?
Amazing.
I'm hungry.
A tear to a glass eye?
Yeah, yeah.
That's how serious I am.
I don't know. Let me tell you
what I went through
and how I experienced this.
I‐I‐I did a deal called
Bubba Baker's Boneless Ribs,
and Bubba had sauces.
What we found out ‐‐
It was so hard
to sell
barbecue sauce online
because people
can't visually taste it,
they're very, very heavy,
and a lot of breakage.
We ended up selling
the barbecue sauce
because the barbecue sauce
was in the ribs,
a small sample of it.
People would taste it
and then reorder.
But if we didn't have
that lead‐in
to grab the people
to give them the tasting,
we would have never sold
any sauce,
and I know the issues here,
and I can't help you with this.
Before you ‐‐
So I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I find the product packaging
a little confusing.
Consumers are very fickle.
When they walk though
that shelf space,
you know,
it looks very Asian to me.
Jorrae: Mm‐hmm.
Right.
I ‐‐ And then I see
"barbecue sauce,"
and yet you told me
it's good for everything.
Everything.
Right.
I think you've come
a really, really long way.
You bagged a massive elephant
in terms of Walmart.
You've got a great test.
You know, the branding
will probably have
to change a little bit,
but it almost feels to me
like it's at the beginning.
Amazing job, but I just
don't think I'm the partner
at this point for you.
Okay.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Greiner: When I look at you,
reminds me of a saying ‐‐
"Some women fear the fire.
Some women become it."
You have become it, and
you have done an amazing job.
Mm‐hmm.
And you have an amazing partner
in Walmart.
For me,
when I invest in something,
I like to invest
in things that are unique.
But there are a million
barbecue sauces out there,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Cuban: Guys, you deserve
a ton of credit.
My challenge is,
I need to see a company
that's going to do
$10 million in sales
or $50 million in sales
over the next 10 years,
even five years, right?
But we're definitely
that company, Mark.
I know you want to be.
Well, I believe that we are,
and here's why ‐‐
because we've had conversations
with Walmart
and with ShopRite,
and all of those guys.
The expansion piece of it,
we've got that nailed, you know?
Yes.
It will happen.
Mm‐hmm.
It's just not gonna happen
in the next two or three years.
Even if you get out
to 1,000 stores
selling, you know,
700 a week,
your business will grow,
and it'll be a great,
profitable business for you,
but that doesn't
necessarily mean
it's an investable business
for me.
So, for those reasons, I'm out,
but, again, congratulations.
Thank you.
You guys
deserve just a ton of credit.
‐Thanks.
‐Good luck, ladies.
Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Kelly:
You know what?
I do not feel like
it was a wasted effort.
I would do it all again.
We know that it's going
to be the sauce
in every single household.
It's not a matter of if...
but when.
But when.
The chances of that
actually being successful,
even with the Walmart ‐‐
Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Herjavec: You are so ‐‐
Oh, no.
Walmart will get behind them.
‐Success is relative.
‐Did you know everything
when you started
your first business?
Look, I'm looking at it
saying "no chance."
It's a total commodity.
Kevin, what you're missing ‐‐
What you're missing is ‐‐
So, they are dying to take
a company like that.
I'm not missing anything.
You can sell it ‐‐
I noticed you didn't put
a dime into it.
‐What?
‐The issue is scale.
It's not whether or not
they'll be profitable,
because they can sell it, they
can hire more people to sell it.
It's just how much.
$500,000 a year ‐‐
My whole point
about these dialogues
we're having with these people
with all this glowing
encouragement is,
you're not giving them
the real risk profile
of what they're spending
their time doing.
Okay, let's ‐‐ Okay, Kevin,
let's talk about the ‐‐
That's the truth.
Let's talk
about the risk profile.
That's the truth.
Kevin, you're an idiot.
Okay, let me tell you ‐‐
Let me tell you ‐‐
Somebody needs
to tell them the truth.
Thank goodness I'm here, Mark.
Thank goodness I'm here.
So, Kevin ‐‐ Kevin,
do you think maybe ‐‐
Because, you know,
all this glowing stuff,
that means the three of them
spend the next two years
trying to sell a hot sauce?
Listen to me, Kevin!
Listen!
I'm not doing
this "Kumbaya" stuff.
No, I'm not saying "Kumbaya."
And she has another job.
You said they should stop.
They should really assess
whether or not it's worth
the next two years
to try and take ‐‐
Abso‐[bleep]‐lutely.
‐Look how far she's come.
‐What are we supposed to do?
Wait a minute.
What are we supposed to do?
Say, "You know what?
Give up."
My point is...
"Don't keep going because you're
never gonna get anywhere."
...I would like to see
a little more truth.
Then don't ‐‐ Look.
How about telling them
the truth?
Kevin ‐‐
What's wrong with that?
But you don't know
the truth.
And what would you have said
about my earring organizer?
It's like Daymond
selling T‐shirts.
Because do you know
how many people said to me,
"This is never gonna go
anywhere."
‐The best ‐‐
‐Look.
"You're not gonna get
in any stores.
Nobody needs this product."
If I had listened
to any of them,
I would not be
where I am today.
If I tried to find the hardest
profit category to go into...
I'm gonna go eat
some barbecue sauce.
...to get market share in,
I think it would be
the barbecue‐sauce business.
I remember
the guy who told me ‐‐
There is no such thing
as an easy business.
‐Oh, my God. Order in the Tank.
‐She knows that.
O'Leary: But there
are some businesses
that are born in hell,
and this is one of them.
I would rather work
80 hours a week to make 50K
and work for myself than
have a $75,000, $100,000 job
working for somebody else.
Greiner: Exactly.
If ‐‐ If you guys
loved it so much,
how come not a dime
from any of you ‐‐
It's her business.
Not one dime.
Just this "Kumbaya"
you keep going stuff.
We all gave good excuses.
We didn't sit here
going, "Kumbaya."
Good excuses?
I told them the truth.
I didn't have
to give them an excuse.
Shame on you.
Where's your eject button?
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is an idea to ease the hassle
of packing
and traveling with luggage.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Aaron.
And I'm Andrew.
We're the co‐founders of unPack.
Today we're seeking
a $500,000 investment
for 40% equity
of our company.
Sharks, we both flew here
from New York,
and I paid $50
to check my bag on a plane.
50 bucks.
For that kind of money,
flying must have been a breeze.
Actually, I wasted
more time packing,
took me longer
to get to the airport,
and then when we landed,
I had to wait 30 minutes
just to pick up my bag.
Huh, I didn't pack a thing.
I just wore the clothes
on my back.
What do you mean,
you didn't pack?
Well, I used unPack.
unPack?
Where did your clothes
come from?
Did you steal them?
No, I didn't steal them,
but they're not my clothes.
UnPack's clothes are better.
How did unPack's clothes
get here?
Good question.
I just went
to unPack's website,
told them where I was going
and when,
and then
when I got to my hotel,
everything I needed
was waiting for me.
So, premium,
location‐aligned luggage
waiting at your hotel
so you don't have to pack.
How can you afford that?
You're not gonna like this,
Aaron,
but I paid less than you did
to check your bag.
Cheaper than my checked bag?
You know, I practically
brought my whole closet here,
and I still feel like
I've got on the wrong clothes.
Yeah,
I don't have that problem.
UnPack is
my personal concierge.
When I go to L. A.,
I'm dressed for L. A.
You think someone like me
could ever unPack?
No.
But since
we're on national television,
we're gonna make
an exception.
And just remember ‐‐ Everything
you need is already there.
Everything I need
is already there.
Sharks, unPack
is ready for takeoff.
Who's coming with us?
Okay, Abbott and Costello.
Tell us about what it costs...
Yep.
... what we can ship,
what we can't ship,
et cetera, et cetera.
Sure. So, right now,
we're shipping everything.
So we're doing
your entire set of clothing.
We're doing
underwear and socks.
Those you get to keep.
Then the only thing we're not
doing is shoes, to date.
Are they men and women?
‐Men and women, yes.
‐So, you're ‐‐
The majority of our customers
to date have been men, though.
But are they used clothes?
They're used clothes.
‐What?
‐So, you recycle them?
‐But they're someone else's?
‐You're kidding.
Like ‐‐ Like,
you ship them to L. A.,
I‐I show up ‐‐
I show up at the hotel.
Yep.
They're there.
I wear my clothes.
Yep.
I put them back in the box.
I ship them back.
That's right.
You clean them.
And then I have to wear
Mark's clothes?
And then the next guy
wears them.
You get a chance
to be Mark Cuban.
I mean, how do you do that?
Well, wait a minute.
That's kind of horrifying.
I don't want
to be Mark Cuban!
John:
Well, all the sizes.
What are they ‐‐ a bunch
of ponchos or something?
You fill out a profile that's
very similar to other companies
in the style‐curation
and clothing‐delivery space.
So we learn a lot about your
size and style preferences.
And then once we know your
brands that you already wear,
we're able to put together
a pack that works for you
in the context
in which you're traveling.
‐What was the age group?
‐And ‐‐ And how much is it?
‐$20 a day.
I go on vacation for five days,
it's $100?
Five days, $100.
Yeah.
Okay, got it.
So, I have a hard time
having things fit me right.
Yeah.
I would be more worried
about what's in that package
sitting there waiting for me,
and I've brought nothing else...
Mm‐hmm.
...that maybe doesn't fit
or I don't like it or whatever.
Mm‐hmm.
What happens
if it doesn't get there?
Great question, and we're
so glad you brought it up
because that's one of the things
that we think
can make our company
really valuable.
This is, first of all,
a problem
that the entire fashion
and e‐commerce industry
is working on to make sure
that they can get the fit right
the first time
and reduce
the return percentage rate.
But, Andrew,
what problem am I solving?
Because you said
at the beginning...
Yep.
...you're saving the fee
to send my own bag.
What's an av‐‐
You're also making
your trip better.
I'm on the trip for five days.
That's $100.
If I'm spending more than two
days, I'm not saving any money.
You are saving money when
you get into the clothes
that are in the box.
You already own
a lot of clothes.
But you say you don't have
to take anything.
Look at Kevin O'Leary.
Yeah.
He would have
to take his shoes,
he would have to take
deodorant and stuff,
his ‐‐ his ‐‐ pack his teeth.
Yeah.
He has a whole lot of things
that he's gonna need
in this bag, right?
Yeah.
‐Pack his what?
‐Teeth.
You don't eliminate the fact
of not having bags.
Liskov: This is why
it's important that we
target the customer,
and this is one of the things
that we benefited
from the six months that we've
been working on this full time,
is that we learned about
who is gonna use this.
Greiner: Okay.
So, you've only done this
for six months?
Kevin O'Leary
is not gonna use ‐‐
‐Why wouldn't I use it?
‐So, do you have sales, and ‐‐
We do. Right now,
we've had 40 bookings,
and we've had
38 people use unPack.
And what are
your reviews like?
Yeah, baby!
‐No, seriously.
‐You've made ‐‐
You've made
hundreds of dollars.
Flex pump. Let's do the flex
for that.
You've made
hundreds of dollars.
Liskov: Better than 37.
No, no.
They've made tens of dollars.
So, yes, our ability
to serve customers
is limited in the beginning,
and that's why we're looking
for capital,
but the market potential here
is huge.
The problem is,
you're brand‐new.
Mm‐hmm.
And you're competing
in two very large markets.
You're competing
for the consumer
that wants to curate clothes.
That's one market.
The other market of saving me
money by checking my bag in ‐‐
That's
a whole different problem,
because you're not really
saving people money.
It's not about the savings.
Okay, so it's not
about the savings.
It's about solving ‐‐
It's about the solving
the inconvenience of ‐‐
But you're solving
the wrong problem, guys.
‐Right.
‐That's the problem.
Greiner: Right.
So, first of all,
your name sucks,
because it suggests that
you're competing with people
that package and ship
for you.
That's what I thought
and I think everybody else
thought you were doing,
as well, right?
‐Yeah.
‐Okay.
Now, put that aside.
What you could do that
would be far better in my mind,
and you ‐‐ It would
save people money, go ‐‐
Are you gonna reinvent
their business plan?
Always.
That's what I always do.
That's so important.
Going to Vegas, right?
Not unPack ‐‐ FunPack.
If I ‐‐ If I can go
to your website, pick Vegas,
click on "club,"
and there's three looks.
Yeah.
And I pick one of those looks,
and it just shows up.
Yep.
That's cool.
That's exactly the company
we want to create.
That's the product.
We ‐‐ We are ‐‐ We are going
in that direction,
and that requires
an overhaul
of the look and feel,
so right now ‐‐
You're asking for $500,000
for us
to redo everything with you.
Not to redo everything.
We're optimizing.
Aaron, tell us in one sentence
what your business is.
We curate and deliver luggage
so you don't have to pack.
‐No.
‐Luggage.
No. Luggage.
You know what?
That's wrong.
‐That's not your business.
I'm gonna tell you
your business.
Their business is,
"We don't know what the hell
we're talking about."
No.
"We rent you fun clothes
for any trip for $20
so you don't have
to buy them."
You guys don't know
what business you're in.
You don't know
how you're gonna get there.
The ‐‐ What you're trying
to sell you're delusional about
'cause it has nothing to do
with luggage and packing.
You guys are confused.
I'm out.
Thanks ‐‐
Thanks for your time.
This business is synchronized
to the trend
in the airline industry...
No.
... to micro‐monetize
every aspect of the experience.
Aaron, the ‐‐ the more
you guys talk ‐‐
Oh, God.
... the more things
you explain,
the more layers
you add to it ‐‐
That just empowers
the value proposition.
Those are ‐‐
Those are ‐‐ Those are
the rational aspects of it.
I don't like
the business idea.
I don't think people
are gonna wear used clothes.
I'm out.
O'Leary: Guys, I'm always
an optimist, you know?
Even when the presentation
is horrendous,
as this one has been.
I'm always looking
for that gem of upside.
I needed to understand
the business model
right out of the gate
early on
because it's just
opportunistic at this point.
And if you had been
much better at doing that,
maybe, maybe you'd get
a deal here today,
but things aren't going well.
I'm out.
I have absolutely no problem
with the ‐‐ the amount
of people you sold to
because then it wouldn't be
a great opportunity, right?
I have
a tuxedo‐rental company.
You know
what the biggest issue we have?
Cleaning.
Mm‐hmm.
Right.
We have a warehouse
a million square feet,
and we can only basically rent
a tuxedo 12 times
before we have
to throw it away.
But you still don't
take away the luggage issue.
Many of the travelers are
going to need to bring things
that are very personal
to them.
Mm‐hmm.
I can't take this ride
with you.
I'm out.
This is a new concept.
It's experimental,
and that's why we think
that it has
a lot of potential.
People said the same thing about
bottled water 30 years ago.
Oh, my God.
You guys,
you have to really stop
and look at,
what is this business?
Mm‐hmm.
There are so many pieces to this
that I'm sorry to say it,
but I see it as a complete
and total nightmare.
I'm out.
Time to go packing.
‐That was brutal.
‐[ Groans ]
I think it's easy to walk out
of a situation like that
and say, "Oh, man, well,
this is a losing battle,"
but this is a new idea,
and people don't know
what it looks like
'cause it hasn't ‐‐
It hasn't been done yet.
Narrator: Back in season five,
Melissa and Rick Hinnant
made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their fashion sock company
Grace & Lace.
You picked the smartest person
here. Good for you.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Melissa: Today is a huge day
for Grace & Lace.
We're finally
in our new facility,
and Barbara arrives
to welcome our first intern.
Rick, Melissa.
Hey!
Hi!
Rick: Before "Shark Tank," we
did a little over $1 million.
It's been three years,
and we've just crossed
$19 million in sales.
We had six employees.
Now we have 47.
$19 million in sales
allowed us
to do the charitable work
that our hearts desire.
We've been able to open
seven orphanages in India,
and we have plans to open
schools in India and Nepal
to give these kids
a very bright future.
‐There she is.
‐Hey!
We're welcoming Kendall,
our first intern.
She's gonna be our ambassador
to our schools in India,
where they are being taught
a skilled trade,
which gives them a chance
at a career path.
Well, I think we have
a lot of work to do.
What do you say?
The new internship program
is just another way
that Grace & Lace
is gonna give back.
They're taking young girls
with an interest in design,
and they're gonna teach them how
to make a living in this field.
Hi, Susanna.
How are you?
Corcoran: I've been making so
much money on this investment,
but the satisfaction now
is seeing
how much good they're doing.
So, I heard
you're interested in fashion.
Never in a million years
did I think that knitting
would turn into a global brand
of women's apparel.
Now we're growing
our business,
we're rescuing orphans
overseas,
and we're growing
our own family.
We have three beautiful kids
that just mean the world to us,
and we couldn't have done it
without "Shark Tank."
Together: Grace & Lace!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a product
to ensure
you and your loved ones
are always protected
from the sun.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Dave Cohen.
I'm from Chapel Hill,
North Carolina.
I'm the founder
and C. E. O. of Sunscreenr.
I'm seeking an investment
of $800,000
in exchange for 10% equity.
‐Oh! Ooh.
‐Wow.
Cohen:
Every year in the United States,
we spend $1.3 billion
on sunscreen.
Yet there are
still over 3 million new cases
of skin cancer every year.
And sunscreen,
it's our best line of defense
against the dangers
of U. V. rays.
However, you can't see if it's
actually protecting you...
until now.
Sunscreenr literally makes
the invisible visible.
Sunscreenr is a special viewer
that uses technology previously
accessible only to scientists
to allow you to see the areas
of your skin that are protected
and the areas that are not.
When you look through
Sunscreenr,
protected areas appear dark.
Unprotected areas appear light.
You can actually see the spots
where water, sand, or sweat
have worn away your protection.
So, whether you just want
a quick look at your kid's skin,
or you want to check
your own protection,
Sunscreenr has you covered.
Lori,
I'd like to invite you up
to have our Sunscreenr prototype
in action.
We have a U. V. lamp here
which simulates the sun.
You should probably wear
some sunglasses.
Okay.
This is the prototype.
And you can see right here.
There's Lori's hand.
So, what I'd like you to do
is just put a streak of
sunscreen on your hand there...
... and tilt it
toward the camera,
and you can actually see it.
And that's what it's going
to look like when you do it?
‐I can see it.
‐You can?
And you look through.
I can see it.
Okay, we good?
Anybody else want
to come up for a live demo?
Yes. Why don't we try it
on black canvas?
‐Yeah, I want to try it.
‐Sure.
A black canvas.
Interesting.
There you go.
‐Oh, I can.
‐It turns white.
That's really interesting.
So, on me, it turns black...
I'm a white man now!
[ Laughter ]
... and on him, it turns white.
So, what you're seeing is
the shininess of the sunscreen.
Sunscreen's job
is to protect your skin,
and it does that
by absorbing the U. V. rays.
So this is set up
to detect U. V.
It throws out all of the
visible, all of the infrared,
and only shows you the areas
where sunscreen absorbs.
All right, I have a question.
Sure.
So, in the video,
it was very clear to see...
Right.
... how it worked.
When we came up there,
it was very black and white
and kind of grainy
and a little bit harder to see.
So, for one,
that was the video
that goes along
with our Kickstarter campaign,
and it was also outside where
there's a ton more U. V. light.
Dave, how much was
your Kickstarter campaign?
So far, in five weeks,
we've raised $93,000.
O'Leary:
What was your target?
$45,000.
Are you shipping
the finished product yet?
No. We will be shipping the
finished product in December.
Ohh.
So, technically,
this is your viewer?
That's right.
So, it is solely, like, a
monocle or a magnifying glass
to look at your body
or your child's body
to say, where is sunscreen,
where isn't it?
That's exactly right.
So, I have a PhD in biochemistry
and biophysics.
I've spent most of my career
building medical devices,
as well as devices
for the Defense Department
and for forensic use.
‐Ooh.
‐Now, you're credible.
I got it.
Why is it worth
$8 million today?
Cohen: Today.
Ooh.
Five weeks after going public
with this thing,
I've already sold 1,200 of these
on Kickstarter.
1,200, though, is not ‐‐
is not a huge amount.
$90,000, which is a run rate
of nearly $1 million a year.
‐But how do you get to ‐‐
‐Oh, come on!
Now you're getting into the ‐‐
Eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh!
You can't do that.
‐Okay, but, Dave ‐‐
‐You know that.
‐You're brilliant.
‐Dave, if you're a PhD,
you know
you can't extrapolate that.
What price point
are you gonna sell them at?
So, right now, the list price
on Kickstarter is $109.
What does it cost you
to make?
In the lowest quantity,
it costs us $45 each to make.
Dave, who told you to put
a value of $8 million on it?
That's the question,
'cause I ‐‐
But, Dave, are you ‐‐
Dave, seriously. Who put...
Dave, I think we're all
struggling with the valuation.
Cohen:
So, within the first few weeks
of launching the Kickstarter,
we were contacted by five
different sunscreen companies,
two of which are
multi‐billion‐dollar
global companies...
Okay.
...interested
in partnering with us.
Licensing the technology
or selling your product
with their sunscreen?
So far, we're in very early
discussions with all of them.
So, Dave...
what does interest mean?
In part, we were holding them
all off
until we had this opportunity
to present it to you guys.
Cuban: Dave, let's just say
I'm hanging with my three kids
and I make
the perfect application...
Mm‐hmm.
... of sunscreen.
Of all the sunscreen
applications ever,
this was the best.
Okay.
Okay?
How long does that last?
30 minutes if they're ‐‐
if they're in the water,
jumping in and out of the water
every 30 minutes?
If you want
to protect them properly.
You're only gonna use this
if you're diligent, right?
Right.
Right, so you have
to have the discipline
to do it in the first place.
Or every time your child
comes out of the water,
you bring out Sunscreenr,
have a quick look.
That's the problem.
You can't have a quick look.
You can, because you hit
the power button.
By the time it's up to your eye,
it's on, and you can see.
But I've got to check ‐‐
You've got to turn them around,
you've got to ‐‐
No, no, no, no.
It has a wide field of view
like your cellphones.
It's not a microscope.
It acts like
a wide‐view camera.
I just think you have sold
yourself so intently
on the value of this,
you've lost
all self‐awareness and context
about the actual business.
I'm out.
Dave, I don't buy the premise
that people are gonna check
every 30 minutes,
however long.
You're telling me they are,
but you haven't validated it.
Your PhD makes you
a credible scientist,
but when you come out with
a $8 million valuation,
you better have a PhD
in business,
in customer research.
You better have
a freakin' PhD
in something
besides your own hype.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I've listened to you, and
I understand the risks of it.
But everybody has the same
problem with the valuation.
It's not worth
$8 million today.
Here's the deal
I propose to you.
I'll give you the $800,000
for 33 1/3%.
I appreciate that.
The valuation, of course,
is way too much.
I cannot sell a kidney
to be part of this company.
[ Laughter ]
So...
You wouldn't get $800,000.
Yes, I would.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
Your valuation ‐‐
If you had come in
with something more reasonable
to me,
I would be giving you
an offer.
I wouldn't even think twice.
But I think that your ‐‐
What's a reasonable valuation?
What would ‐‐
What would make sense to you
given your experience?
Listen, Dave,
you're a smart guy.
Show me.
What offer?
Give me an offer.
Tell me what you want
to hear from me.
Would you go $800,000 for 20%?
No. I wouldn't.
Okay,
so, you have one offer.
I'll give you $800,000
for 33 1/3%.
What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna counter back,
Lori?
There is nothing tangible here
for me to really understand
if the consumer
is going to buy into...
‐Are you in?
‐... using this.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
‐All right. Thank you.
‐Wow.
Herjavec: Dave,
you're left with one offer.
‐I'm left with Kevin.
‐Okay, so, Dave...
Kevin's only offered
$800,000 for 1/3.
Would you do 25%?
No.
That's a lot of money, Dave.
$800,000 for 33 1/3%.
It's the only offer
you have.
What are you gonna do?
We have a deal.
Oh!
What?!
You got it.
Thank you.
Good luck, Dave.
Kevin's a good negotiator,
and ‐‐ and since he was
the last Shark, you know,
I didn't want
to lose the opportunity
to have a Shark
as part of our team.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business
that delivers an unusual twist
to a common product.
[ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Alex Craig.
And I'm Riad Bekhit.
Our company
is seeking $50,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our business.
Look, Sharks,
over the years,
you've heard all types
of elaborate, intricate,
and over‐the‐top pitches.
Well, we're here
to keep it simple,
so let's take this pitch
back to our roots.
Sharks, our company
is Potato Parcel,
and we mail potatoes,
and that's it.
Any questions?
Maybe too simple.
Explain it again.
So, Potato Parcel
is a brand‐new way
of sending anyone you know
a custom message
written on a potato.
It's just stupid on a stick,
right?
It's ‐‐ It's actually stupid
on a potato.
Stupid on a potato. Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a potato company?
Yes, it's a potato.
Oh, I thought the outfit
was a pair of testicles.
[ Laughter ]
‐Potatoes.
‐Oh, my.
Get closer together
for one second.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no.
You're right!
‐Oh, my God.
‐As soon as they're...
It's the same thing
every morning!
‐It's the same thing.
‐Lord.
O'Leary: Let's walk through
the business model.
I want to send somebody
a message.
You're gonna write
on a potato for me?
Yes.
So, how much does it cost me
to do that?
Wait a minute.
We need our samples.
‐Let's start with the samples.
‐Absolutely.
Greiner: Like, how are
we talking about something
when we don't even know
what it looks like?
‐Cool.
‐Does it come in a box?
It comes in a bubbled envelope
and special packaging
that we're gonna include
right here for you guys.
‐Robert, this one's for you.
‐Thank you.
Oh, it comes like this.
‐Lori.
Lori, we have a special one.
‐I get the sweet potato.
Oh!
‐The sweet potato.
‐Kevin.
‐Daymond.
‐Thank you.
‐And Mark.
‐What's it say on yours?
It says, "Lori, would you be
my sweet potato?"
All right.
‐Aww.
‐Mine has a picture of me.
‐Lori.
Mine's a very handsome potato.
And mine says, "There's nothing
proprietary about this."
‐How true.
‐And I think ‐‐
And I think
this potato is right.
We knew you'd love it.
This potato's
absolutely right.
So, gentlemen,
what happened to your careers?
What went wrong?
How, Alex?
How did you come up with this?
Yeah, I was on Reddit,
and the top post of the day
was a potato with stamps on it,
and I thought
that was a really funny idea
that you could mail someone
a potato.
1.5 million people saw
a potato with stamps on it,
and I just saw
an opportunity.
Did anybody
buy the potato message?
To date, we've sold
over 12,000 potatoes
and put over 12,000 smiles
and expressions of confusion
on people's faces.
[ Laughter ]
What are your costs?
So, the Potato Parcel with just
the message on it is $9.99.
The one you have,
Mark and Robert...
[ Chuckling ] No.
...the Potato Pal ‐‐
How much is...
‐Is this a Potato Pal?
‐That's a Potato Pal.
‐Aww.
Bekhit: So, that's $14.99.
And we also have the Potato
Postcard, which is $12.99.
‐Why is this one so much more?
‐Can you just mail the potato
with a stamp on it?
‐So...
Or do you actually have
to put it in a box?
So, actually,
when I started the business,
I showed up
to the post office
with a potato
with stamps on it.
I said, "Hey, can I mail this?"
and they said, "Absolutely.
We can mail that for you."
No, they can't.
And I said, "Great.
I have 500 of them."
It's automated.
And then they said,
"You can't mail
that many potatoes."
So we actually now put it
in an envelope
as a means
for surprise and delight.
Bekhit: And, guys, we want
to show you
some of our other products.
Yeah.
‐Oh, you have more?
‐Great.
Bekhit: So, we're very seasonal
at Potato Parcel,
and we have our Spooky Tater
for Halloween,
our sweet potato for your
sweetie on Valentine's Day,
and the potato ornament
for your Christmas tree.
So, how much revenue
have you guys generated
since you started?
So, in 13 months,
we've done $215,000 in sales.
John: Wow.
And how much do you put
in your pocket?
Well, I typically don't like
to pay myself much
to keep more cash flow
in the business
since we're still young.
So, you're reinvesting
your profits, huh?
Yes.
Into what ‐‐ inventory?
Inventory, hiring to help
with order fulfillments.
So, seriously, though,
you do 215,000 real dollars,
and rather
than just thinking,
"We just made out
like bandits.
Let's put the money
in our pocket"...
You keep going at it.
...you keep on thinking you're
gonna keep the business growing.
Bekhit:
Our customers really love us.
They're always posting
about us online.
They're reordering.
We have ‐‐ We have
over 600, 700 repeat customers.
Do you have day jobs?
So, I work at a mobile‐app
agency in Dallas, Texas.
And your day job
is mailing potatoes?
So, Riad, you don't ‐‐
‐I do this full time, yes.
‐If I go on the website ‐‐
You guys ‐‐
Are you guys 50/50 partners?
No. So, when I started
the website,
my goal was to go viral.
So, once we hit the peak
of our viral‐‐ viralness,
Riad actually purchased
the website for...
So he owns 100%.
I bought the 100% of the
business from Alex for $42,000.
Why do you still walk around
in a potato outfit?
Well, it's been my dream
to get on "Shark Tank."
Herjavec: There you go.
Actually, I've applied
for the past four years.
But there's no equity in it
for you.
You own nothing.
So, you sold ‐‐
Actually, there is.
When I signed basically the
agreement to buy Potato Parcel,
100% of it from Alex,
there was a contingency.
Since he was in touch
with "Shark Tank,"
the contingency
was that if we got on the show,
he would be entitled
to $1 per potato
for the first 60 days
of airing on "Shark Tank."
So, you got "Shark Tank"
schmuck insurance?
Yes.
But no equity.
So, you're basically saying
you ripped off my royalty deal?
I did.
Outrageous!
Riad, what were you
actually buying?
I was buying
the whole business, the rights,
the training from Alex
to help me run the business.
[ Laughter ]
It's been an awesome investment
this far.
Awesome as defined by?
Like, you've made money?
Continued growth in sales,
the PR that we've gotten.
So, what did you do
in sales last month?
$25,000.
Our products
are 70% to 78% margin.
What did your parents think
when you told them you were ‐‐
So, I had to really sell them
on this,
'cause they thought
it was just a waste of money.
All my peers thought
this was something stupid.
Guys, I really ‐‐
I really like it.
I think it's cute.
I think it's gonna ‐‐
I think you're gonna sell
a lot of potatoes.
You know
the valuation is nuts.
Because we've done in 13 months
$215,000,
we really feel
that's ‐‐ that's a good deal.
‐Yeah.
‐What are you doing?
I'll be very honest ‐‐
I just can't even believe
that they're entertaining
this offer.
I'm gonna sit back
and relax and watch it, okay?
So I'm out.
[ Laughing ]
Don't stand together.
I personally think
that taking this seriously
as far as a Shark investing
is crazy.
‐Yes.
‐I'm out.
Can you guys
stop standing together?
Just separate a little bit.
‐Mark, what are you doing?
‐It's not completely crazy.
Cuban: Look, if you believe
the potato business
is a growth industry,
it's fair.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Riad and Alex have
three more chances to get a deal
for their potato‐delivery
service, Potato Parcel.
Cuban: Look, if you believe
the potato business
is a growth industry,
it's fair.
In order to make this work,
I need to see a path
to $100 million in sales.
How big do you guys
think you can get?
Mark, we think we can get to $5
million to $10 million in sales.
Straightly off potatoes?
Well, we have plans for retail,
as well.
‐Retail?!
‐So, in the ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
The ‐‐
You guys are gonna make
good money, right?
You're already making
20 grand a month off of it
just writing on potatoes,
but I need ‐‐
You are so full of beep.
I need more sub‐‐
I need more substance.
And...these are
just empty calories,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
O'Leary: I'm struggling
with the valuation.
However, because I'm creative,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Oh, God.
Let the Sharks learn
from Mr. Wonderful.
I'm gonna give you the $50,000,
and I'm gonna take the 10%,
but I'm gonna join Alex
on his royalty journey,
and his royalty's
getting cut in half
because I'm getting
half of his royalty.
Wow.
Why would Alex do that?
For the first 60 days ‐‐
Well,
we actually signed a ‐‐
Wait. I'm not finished.
It gets better.
Okay.
So, after he's got
his 50 cents for 60 days,
I continue to get a dollar
until I've got back $150,000.
Then I'm gonna hire you
to go work
in one of my real companies,
'cause this thing's gonna go
to zero at some point.
Even I know that,
and so do you.
I'm doing this for your parents,
really,
'cause I'm worried about you.
‐Set you free.
So, Riad,
I have an offer for you.
‐You do?!
‐I do.
It's ‐‐
It's crazy, it's fun.
I think you'll move
a lot of potatoes.
Forget the valuation.
You gave Alex $42,000.
I'll give you the $50,000
for 25% of the business.
We move a lot of potatoes.
We sell a lot of stuff.
Maybe we expand.
Maybe we expand
into cucumbers.
‐You are so freakin' nuts.
‐Carrots. Who knows?
‐What are you doing?
‐I'm making an offer.
It's fun. It's crazy.
‐So...
Greiner: You guys,
you better grab this fast
before they, like,
come back down to earth.
So, he wants 20%
for the $50,000.
Don't hate me
because I'm crazy and fun.
My offer is much less equity.
You don't take as much pain.
You're delirious.
You let go a minute.
You realize that you've
negotiating to a scrotum?
You understand that?
On national television.
I think this is gonna ‐‐
So, I have ‐‐
I have an answer for you.
Okay.
And the crazy thing is,
you guys,
they're fighting over you,
which is insane.
So...
So you need to think
about this quickly...
Lori.
... because
they could both quit.
Let them respond, Lori.
Let them respond.
Let the potato speak.
Robert, so,
giving us $50,000 for 25%,
that's valu‐‐ valuing us
at $200,000,
and we just did $215,000
in 13 months.
That doesn't seem like
a good deal to me.
‐So unfair. I agree.
‐Good for you, potato.
Do you have a counter?
I'd like 17 1/2% for you,
Robert.
And what about for Kevin?
So, I would like to be loyal
to Alex
for helping getting us
to this point.
Yes.
I'd like to still give him
a dollar and you a dollar.
Yes.
After $150,000,
I‐I'd still own 10%, right?
Correct.
So, Riad, which option
do you like better?
The royalty deal
or the equity deal?
I'd like to hear from you guys,
if you don't mind,
what your ‐‐ what value
you would bring to us.
[ Laughter ]
Riad, you know what?
I own a pretty big
cybersecurity company
all over the world.
I was waiting for the ‐‐
I think your customers
are gonna like them.
I was waiting for the right time
to exit that business
and get into
another business.
I am selling that business,
and I'm going full time
for the potato.
I‐I will ‐‐
I will help you.
Mwah!
Every waking moment I have,
I'm gonna be thinking
about this business.
[ Laughter ]
Both ‐‐ Both offers
seem really good,
and I‐I really love
both of you guys.
I think the most sense would be
to make a deal with Kevin.
‐Whoa, yes!
‐You got a deal, Kevin.
‐Mr. Potato!
‐Yes!
Yes!
‐Wow.
Thank you so much.
I'm really looking forward
to working with your company.
‐Oh, man.
‐This is absolutely terrific.
Greiner: You look like
a potato with them.
Give them a big hug.
Kevin, give them a big hug.
Go back up there.
‐Aah!
Cuban: Riad, Riad,
just got to ask you.
John: That is horrible!
Have you always
had this delivery,
or do you, like, copy
Jimmy Kimmel on purpose?
Oh, no, I just felt that.
That's great.
Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐All right.
‐Dude.
‐Yes!
Bekhit: I can't believe
we got a deal.
I can't believe the company's
been growing this much,
and I‐I really can't wait
to see what's gonna happen
with this business.
We're really gonna take over
the world of potatoes.
I really believe it.